– Michael Audrey Myers was born in 1957, as
the second, and FINAL child of Edith and Donald
Myers after his nine year old sister, Judith.
In this video, I’m analyzing the latest
version of the Michael Myers character, from
the 40 Year Timeline.
That includes Halloween, Halloween (2018),
Halloween Kills and Halloween Ends.
Most cities have a union station or joint
station where most of their routes connect.
In the case of the Halloween Express, that
is Halloween (1978).
From there, you can go down the original route,
where Michael is involved with a cult worshiping
an ancient demon, you can go down the 20 Year
Timeline route, where Michael escapes after
getting blown up by Dr. Loomis, or you can
go down the 40 Year Timeline route, where
Michael is captured, and locked up for 4 decades.
So his origin in this timeline is mostly a
familiar one… but not entirely.
Things would take a twist.
In this video, you’ll learn how this iteration
of Michael Myers was modeled after Jaws, the
meaning of his signature traits like the head
tilt and the answer to the one question on
everyone’s mind: is this the end of Michael
Myers?
To find out, stick around to the end of this
video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History.
One of the goals set by co-writers David Gordon-Green
and Danny McBride was to make the Michael
Myers character scary again.
To do this, they looked back to the original,
which included no familial relations, no complex
backstories, and no ove explanations of the
character.
Producer Jason Blum and David Gordon-Green
have both described their approach as walking
the line between honoring the old and twisting
that into something new.
For example, Michael’s look and body language
are closer to that of the original than ever
before, but they weren’t opposed to ramping
up the blood and gore to keep up with the
modern slasher, something we didn’t really
see during Michael’s first appearance in
the more conservative 1970s.
The most important direction for a contemporary
boogeyman was to re-introduce the mystique,
and that comes across in the way he’s written,
acted, and even in the design of his iconic mask.
– [McBride] There’s something scary about
someone committing those kinds of violent
acts with no emotion at all, and that’s
what that mask does.
You can project your own things that frighten
you onto that mask.
Special FX designer Chris Nelson created the
mask with the goal of preserving the melancholy
of the character, and many fans agree that
it was effective in using a blank slate to
bring back the horror of what might be.
Other timelines mess up the illusion of emotionlessness
by showing his face, making him cry, explaining
his childhood in great detail, or in some
cases, just using masks that look too surprised
or too angry.
“I'd like to know as little about him or
his history and abilities as possible,”
the director offered (in an interview with
HalloweenMovies.com.
“I think there was a reason he was called
The Shape in the original because in some
ways he's more of an essence than he is a
traditional character.”
While this is a valid point, I also think
that the very practice of doing a sequel trilogy
results in new lore being added to the character.
This one goes back to the idea that Michael
Myers is human, but with a supernatural edge;
he’s nearly invincible.
– [Carpenter] A character who is between
human being and the supernatural.
– And he’s a human being, we need to understand.
– And with more scenes to study, we can start
to recognize patterns and draw a few conclusions
about him, without disrupting the mysterious
allure that has made him a legend for so many decades.
We’ve got a lot of ground to cover, so let’s
get into it.
(ominous piano)
As a child, Michael was an outcast.
While he didn’t exhibit any alarming behavior,
he didn’t seem to exhibit much behavior at all.
This caused some adults to feel bad for him,
including the mother of a boy in his class,
Peter McCabe.
Mrs. McCabe would make her son go over to
Michael’s house to play, but Michael would
spend all of his time just staring out his
sister’s window.
At the age of six years old, on October 31st,
1963.
Michael’s parents go out for the evening,
and his older sister is hanging out with her
boyfriend, leaving him unsupervised.
After seeing Judith and her boyfriend go upstairs,
he takes a knife from the kitchen and heads
up himself.
Judith is combing her hair when the boy creeps
up and stabs her several times.
He simply walks outside and stands in front
of the house as his parents come home to discover
his crime.
He was taken into the custody of the Illinois
Department of Public Safety - Juvenile Justice
on November 1st.
Officials at the time stated he likely would
not be charged with first-degree murder, pending
a psychological evaluation.
After the evaluation, it was decided he would
undergo psychiatric treatment.
Michael is labeled as patient number A-2201,
sentenced to Smith’s Grove Sanitarium and
assigned to a psychiatrist named Dr. Samuel
Loomis.
His initial stay at Smith’s Grove lasted
15 years, none of which is documented in the
Halloween films.
– Michael Audrey Myers shall be
brought before the court on the day of his
21st birthday, where he shall be tried as
an adult.
– For those who are wondering, this scene is
one of the extra scenes shot for the television
version of the original 1978 film.
Long story short, they wanted to add scenes
to fit a television time slot with more commercials.
The question is, if these scenes are still
canon in the 40 Year Timeline, because in
Halloween 2018, we see this: Michael’s middle
initial is A.
The name Michael Audrey Myers comes from these
made for TV scenes.
It’s totally possible that this was
intended to be an easter egg though, because
another made for TV scene shows that Michael
wrote the word “sister” on his door before
breaking out of Smith’s Grove.
This suggests that he broke out to go after
his sister, Laurie, which he does in Halloween II.
However, Michael and Laurie are not siblings
in the 40 Year Timeline.
Co-writer Danny McBride has talked about this
change.
“I was pushing for the removal of the familial
mythology set-up in Halloween 2 right off
the bat.
I just felt like it was an area where he wasn't
quite as scary anymore.
It seemed too personalized.”
The idea was that the audience knows they’re
not related to Michael, so they didn't have anything
to worry about.
But if he’s just going after random people,
everyone has a reason to be afraid.
It’s possible that Michael wrote “sister”
in reference to Judith, whose tombstone he
steals after breaking out.
So you could make an argument either way as
to the canonicity of these added scenes.
My take is that they are not part of the 40
Year Timeline.
The extra scenes were shot using the crew
from Halloween II, and they aired in 1980,
right before Halloween II, so it’s pretty
clear that they’re meant to set up that movie.
Halloween (2018) takes a strong stance in
that it only acknowledges Halloween 1, going
so far as to say that Halloween II was just
made up.
– [Dave] Wasn’t it her brother who, like,
cold blooded murdelated all those teenagers?
– [Allyson] No.
That’s just a bit that some people made
up to make them feel better I think.
– In 1978, after Michael turned 21, he was due
back in court for re-evaluation, but when
Dr. Loomis and his associate Nurse Marion
Chambers arrived to pick him up, he and several
other patients were on the loose.
Michael stole their car and escaped into the
night in Warren County.
This version of the Michael Myers character
plays into his status as an urban legend.
And it makes sense, because Halloween (2018),
Kills and Ends are aimed at a new generation.
A generation who has probably heard of Michael
Myers, but not yet experienced him for themselves,
much like an urban legend.
Think about the popular urban legends of our
culture.
There are always repeating elements and symptoms.
Bloody Mary will appear if you say her name
into a mirror three times with only a candle’s light.
Slenderman will appear nestled in forest trees
and cause glitches in video equipment.
The lights will flicker on and off before
the appearance of The Hash Slinging Slasher.
In Michael’s case, he comes out around Halloween
night, surrounded by a fleet of wraith-like
mental patients.
There are many other symptoms of the urban
legend that are seen by multiple generations
of Haddonfield residents, which I’ll point
out throughout this lesson.
First example: in 1963, Michael had a one
piece clown suit, a mask and a knife; and
he targeted a teenager who had been getting
busy with her boyfriend.
So in 1978, the legend would continue with
Michael obtaining a one piece jumpsuit, a
mask and a knife; and he would once again
target teenagers who are trying to do the
act, as stand-ins for Judith.
He runs a mechanic’s truck off the road
and offs him to get the suit.
To make this night a tribute to his last rampage,
he steals Judith’s tombstone from the cemetery.
He breaks into the general store to steal
a Halloween mask, and also gets some rope,
which he would use later,
in addition to picking up his now signature weapon, a couple of knives.
His next stop is his childhood home, which
now sits abandoned.
It is here that he gets hungry, and eats part
of a dog.
And it is also here where he first encounters
Laurie Strode, a high school student who is
there to drop off a set of keys for her father,
who is a realtor trying to sell the property.
He follows her around all day until she arrives
at her babysitting job that evening.
Her friend Annie is babysitting across the
street, and she becomes the next victim.
Michael hides in her car, so when she goes
to pick up her boyfriend, he strangles her
before she gets out of the garage.
His next victims are Bob and Lynda, who are
trying to use the house as a private place
to do their thing.
He arranges all three dead teens in the upstairs
bedroom with Annie on the bed under the Judith
Myers tombstone, making it clear that he’s
trying to recreate the scenario from his youth.
He stuffs Lynda in a cupboard and hangs Bob
overhead in the closet.
Then he kills the lights in the house and
waits for Laurie to notice
and come over to check on her friends.
When she does she’s demonstrably distrubed,
but her next find is even more horrifying.
(screams)
Michael slowly but methodically chases her
back across the street to the Doyle household
and makes several more attempts on her, but
she puts up a good fight, first stabbing him
in the neck with a knitting needle, then poking
his eye out with a clothing hanger and finally
stabbing him in the chest with the knife he
dropped.
But Michael Myers is far from any ordinary
man, and rises back to life in an almost vampire
like fashion.
He gets ahold of his exhausted prey, finally
seeing his chance to end it by strangling
her, but she does something unexpected by
removing his mask.
This causes him to stop momentarily and he
attempts to put it back on before continuing
to attack her.
His fixation with the mask is never detailedly
explained, but it’s obviously an important
part of the process for him.
In the original timeline, I analyzed the mask
as an important part of the ritualistic practice
he’s taking part in, but here in the 40
Year Timeline, Michael is simply an escaped
mental patient.
It’s a common occurrence for mental patients
to respond poorly to any change outside their
comfortable normal.
That’s why mental institutions never deviate
from having simple white walls with no decorations.
The staff are always dressed identically,
with the same inoffensive music played every day.
The same old boring facility actually creates
a calm, safe environment for the patients.
We also see this with a character in the 40
Year Timeline, Mr. Tivoli.
He has a fixation with tied shoelaces, and
anything else is upsetting to him.
Michael was wearing a mask and one piece costume
when he killed his sister in 1963, so he feels
the need to wear similar attire, mask included,
to kill during the anniversary here in 1978,
and the same would be true in the future.
But this little distraction ends up being
a much larger detour.
– I shot him!
I shot him six times!
I shot him!
I shot him in the heart!
I shot him six times!
Fired six shots into him.
– To this point, this would be the most damage
that Haddonfield’s boogeyman had ever taken
on, and it came at the hands of his own psychiatric
doctor, but it doesn’t keep him down for
long; he only needs a couple of seconds to
flee the scene and cut through an alley to escape.
He is spotted by a timid young Officer Frank
Hawkins, who shoots at him, but an unphased
Michael simply walks away, out of sight.
It seems the first thing he does after this
is move his car, because we can see it right
here, parked outside the old Myers house.
Combine that with the breathing we hear at
the end of Halloween while looking across
the street at the house, and it seems likely
that this was the first place he went.
If you think about it, it makes sense that
he’d try to repark the car, because he was
just attacked by Dr. Loomis, who is the most
likely person to recognize that car.
Michael goes back out on foot and comes across
a boy named Lonnie Elam, who had tripped on
the sidewalk.
Michael doesn't kill kids, and he sees a pair
of police officers approaching, so once again,
he miraculously disappears, something he’s
managed to do a number of times now.
He retreats into his old home and stands at
the window, just as he did as a child.
The officers are McCabe, who Michael had play-dates
with in their youth, and Frank Hawkins, who
he had encountered not long before.
They investigate the house where Michael surprises
McCabe, one of the few times we ever see him run.
He slams the officer into the wall several
times and uses the remainder of the rope taken
from the hardware store to strangle him.
We see McCabe manage to get in several good
punches in the abdomen, but Michael hardly
seems to notice, and takes him hostage just
before Hawkins gets into the room and shoots.
But the rookie officer accidentally hits his
partner, rather than the masked perpetrator.
Michael drops his meat shield, and calmly
walks out of the house, even as several more
shots are fired at him.
This entire night, he’s been trying to recreate
the circumstances of his first kill in 1963,
and he brings it all to a close by walking
out of the house and standing in the front
yard, just as he did back then.
This time, he is immediately surrounded by
six armed police officers, who are able to
beat him down, capture him and return him
to captivity, this time in prison.
“Shortly after Myers began his term in the
state prison, he was transferred from medium
to maximum security because he apparently
formulated escape plans.”
He also forged his own identification credentials,
took notes on airplane schedules and somehow
acquired road maps and a driver’s license.
After shooting him six times, Loomis was removed
from his position as Michael Myers’s doctor.
Whether this was voluntary or involuntary
is not known.
In a statement recorded in audio on January
22nd 1979, about three months after the babysitter
murders, he suggests that Myers should get
the death penalty.
– My suggestion is termination.
Death is the only solution for Michael.
– However, the state wanted to keep Michael
alive to be studied, hoping they could gain
more insight on the mind of a killer.
This is probably why he was eventually returned
to Smith’s Grove.
I like to think I’m doing a much better
job of that in this video than they did in
their 55 years of study.
But as I mentioned, Michael is more of an
essence than an actual character.
We can assume Loomis knew this, and kept watch
over Michael with only the intention of keeping
him locked up.
However, he eventually passed away, and his
successor would not have the same intentions.
The next psychiatrist assigned to look over
Michael is a man by the name of Dr. Ranbir Sartain.
Dr. Sartain became obsessed with trying to
understand Michael and his motives and abilities.
This causes Sartain to develop a bond to his
patient and become protective of him, the
same way an artist might defend their own
life’s work.
He brought in over 50 clinical psychiatrists
to try to see Michael, and each had different
opinions about him.
During these 40 years, Michael rarely speaks,
which Sartain sees as a personal choice to
stay silent rather than a disability.
In the years of Michael’s second stint of
captivity, Smith’s Grove Sanitarium became
Smith’s Grove State Hospital.
Patients are calmed with old jazz music on
vinyl records, a courtyard area is outfitted
to give them their own space to get some fresh
air and sunshine every day and Sartain meets
individually with patients to check in on
them on a morningly basis.
After 40 years of not much progress, Michael
was set to be transferred to a new facility,
Glass Hill, and assigned a new doctor on October
30th, 2018, the 40 year mark from the date
of his first escape.
(impact)
(mysterious music)
There are not many visitors for Smith’s
Grove's most infamous resident, so Dr. Sartain
doesn’t have many opportunities to see how
Michael reacts to different people or different
environments.
I imagine this feels quite limiting to him,
and speculate that when British investigative
journalists Aaron Korey and Dana Haines approached
him about speaking to Michael, he gleefully
accepted, with hopes of seeing a new side
of his mysterious long studied mental case.
They were able to arrange a meeting just before
the transfer on October 29th, 2018.
– And there he is.
– When introduced to the reporters, Michael
ignores them, so in order to try to elicit
a response, he brings out the William Shatner
mask that was worn during the 1978 rampage,
but it manages to aggravate just about every
other patient than the one it was intended for.
The evening of the 30th, each of the transferring
patients were lined up and loaded into a caged
school bus outfitted by the Illinois Department
of Corrections.
Curiously, Dr. Sartain sees him through to
the end, and tries to comfort him, something
that seems unnecessary given that Michael
is a well established sociopath.
– Don’t worry Michael.
I’ll be by your side.
– He even fights to go with on the bus, arguing
that Myers is his patient until he’s been
delivered into someone else’s care.
During the ride, the bus crashes into a ditch
on Marlowe Road.
My theory is that Laurie was the one to drive
the bus off the road in hopes of killing Michael,
but things do not go according to plan.
She’s very unstable, and we do see her in
her car overseeing the patient transfer, plus
she hardly seems to react when the accident
is reported in the news.
Someone, presumably Michael after being freed
by Sartain, attacks and seriously injures
the guards and bus driver, allowing the patients
to escape into the night.
I say this because Dr. Sartain previously
expressed frustration in the fact that so
many clinical psychiatrists had looked at
Michael, but only one, Dr. Loomis, had gotten
to study him in the wild.
When a father and son drive up and discover
the accident, they both end up getting out
of the car to look around.
Michael brutally snapped the neck of the father
and stealthily stowed himself away in their
backseat.
The kid encounters the injured guard, who
urges him to just run, leading me to believe
that Michael was in fact the one to attack
him, showing off the unstoppable power that
had faded into legend over the last 40 years.
And that legend was playing out once more
because Michael takes out the kid by surprise-choking
him when he gets back into the vehicle, just
as he did with Annie in 1978.
This also allows him to steal that vehicle,
like he did during that first escape.
To continue with the tradition, his first
stop in Haddonfield is at the cemetery where
his sister, Judith is buried.
He finds the reporters from the previous day
recording more content at the Judith Myers
gravesite and decides to follow them to the
gas station in order to get his mask back.
While Aaron is not looking, Myers walks into
the mechanic’s shop, punches him out, and
steals his suit.
He also bashes an additional employee’s
face in and pockets his teeth, so he can drop
them over the bathroom stall that Dana is
using to scare the sh*t out of her.
Pun kinda intended.
Aaron realizes what’s happening just in
time before his partner is killed, but even
whacking Michael in the face with a crowbar
is not enough to save her, and both of their
lives are taken, allowing Michael to reclaim
his prized mask.
He would only need one more item to finish
his iconic look, and he would waste no time
getting it.
Because it’s Halloween night, he blends
in with the crowd in costume, allowing him
to fly under the radar.
Just like in his last rampage, he bumps into
some little kids, but lets them go.
Even though the one kid comes really close
to dropping an f-bomb.
– Oof!
– What the f-
– BOOOOOOM!
(explosion)
– [Zac] He steals a hammer from the Elrods’ shed
and uses it against Mrs. Elrod so he can claim
her kitchen knife.
And with that, the look is complete.
After 13 Halloween films, I’ve come to appreciate
just how important Michael’s appearance
is when it comes to making him a scary antagonist.
And where’s a good reason for that.
It goes back to the root reason that we are
drawn to horror movies.
Human psychology.
Danny McBride was onto something when he described
what makes Michael scary to him.
He noted the contrast between the horrible
acts Michael commits, and the lack of emotion
that he seems to have while committing them.
This is called incongruent affect.
The literal definition of this term is when
feelings, mood, or emotions do not match up.
In psychology, incongruent affect is when
a patient’s feelings do not match their
appearance, or do not match what is appropriate
for the situation.
It’s fitting that the first costume we ever
see Michael in is the clown costume, because
clowns are the perfect example of incongruent
affect.
Many people find them creepy because their
painted smiles give them the appearance of
always being happy, even if they are not happy,
or the situation does not call for happiness.
That’s why seeing a clown at the circus
probably isn’t so creepy, if done correctly,
because the circus is a happy place and the
clowns are trying to be funny.
But seeing a clown in a sewer grate, stand
pipe or abandoned house is definitely creepy.
That’s incongruent affect.
It comes off as creepy because we, as humans,
are designed to socialize with other humans.
Humans have traditionally lived in tribes
with other humans for safety, so socialization
meant survival.
As a result, our brains have evolved for millions
of years to get really good at picking up
on social cues.
That’s why outlets look like a face.
That’s why cars look like a face.
That’s why Iggy Pop’s torso looks like
it’s about to cry.
We are hardwired to pick up human emotions
using only visual cues.
When those cues don’t match what the person
is really feeling, or don’t match the situation,
we pick up on that too, because it tells us
that something is wrong.
Perhaps it is a predator trying to deceive
us, or there is something wrong with the person,
and we need to heal someone in our tribe.
Seeing Michael slashing up victims, all with
a blank, expressionless stare is an example
of incongruent affect.
Other Halloween films which make Michael look
surprised or angry just don’t have the same
effect.
And that’s why it’s important for Michael
to recollect all of the pieces of his iconic look.
Now that he has his knife, he’s got to test
it out!
And he finds a suitable victim in the house
next door.
This victim seems to be chosen at random,
but the next would be chosen to maintain a
tradition established in ‘78.
His main targets that year were Haddonfield’s
teen babysitters, Annie and Laurie.
This year he finds another babysitter, Vicky,
who is looking after a boy named Julian Morrisey.
Like any good urban legend, the story begins
to repeat itself.
Michael sneaks into the house and stares through
Julian’s bedroom door, but again, isn’t
concerned with killing kids.
It just freaks Julian out and gets him to
run down the stairs for help.
– Ghosts and goblins little buddy?
– Shut up Dave!
I heard him breathing.
And then I saw him!
He’s in here.
The boogeyman’s in this house!
– Michael hides in the closet while the room
is vacated.
Vicky goes up to investigate, but doesn’t
find him there, because she’s not taking
Julian’s warning very seriously.
As she puts him back to bed, he asks her to
close the closet door, but she finds something
is blocking it.
(door jamb)
(loud music and scream)
Michael is undeterred by Vicky throwing a
chair at him so she rushes out of the room,
but slips on the hardwood floor in the hallway,
allowing him to drag her back into the room
and bring the knife down on her.
After taking her out, he cocks his head, something
we saw him do after killing Bob Simms 40 years prior.
This moment is explained by the actor behind
the mask: Nick Castle.
He plays Myers in the original Halloween and
in parts of Halloween (2018).
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
he reveals that director John Carpenter instructed
him to tilt his head like that on the spot.
“I had no idea what he was trying to get
at until I saw the movie and I said, ‘Oh,
how cool, it looks like I’m admiring my
kill.’”
Which makes sense when paired with the pin-up
model comparison I made in my Things You Missed
in Halloween video; it’s almost as if the
body pinned to the wall is seen as a piece
of artwork that Michael is gawking at.
As we discussed, Michael is a mental patient
and a creature of habit, which is why Castle
was instructed to perform the head tilt again
after killing Vicky.
Or at least that’s how I see it.
I’m willing to close the door on that mystery.
(door slams)
Actually, everything he does before leaving
the house is a callback to his Bob Simms kill.
He covers Vicky’s body with a bedsheet,
the same disguise he used for himself, after
finishing Bob, and then his next victim is
Vicky’s boyfriend Dave, who he pins to the
wall with his knife, just as he did to Bob.
Frank Hawkins, now a deputy in his sixties,
shows up to investigate the disturbance and
finds Vicky, but Michael is hiding in a bedroom
on the opposite side of the house, looking
out the window through the reflection of this
mirror.
He makes eye contact with Laurie, the once
17-year old girl who evaded him the last time
he was free.
Now, at 57, she’s more prepared, and fires
a shot in his direction, which might have
at least dealt a blow to his head if she had
realized she was looking through a mirror.
Michael walks out of the house, drawing the
attention of Hawkins, but he cannot land a
shot either.
The discovery of Dave’s body distracts his
attention, so Michael is once again able to
walk out and disappear into the black of the
night.
But this time is different.
This time, Laurie spots him and fires a shot
through the left side of his back before he
completely disappears.
This is the first time that Laurie has turned
the tables on him and become the hunter rather
than the hunted.
Only Loomis was previously able to scare Michael
away up to this point.
He retreats, and manages to get away and take
cover within the fortress of the Elrod’s
backyard, which is surrounded by high concrete
walls.
But eventually, a new victim falls into his
lap.
(impact)
(ominous music)
High school student Oscar Berlucchi is in
a vulnerable state after getting drunk and
rejected by his crush, and mistakes Michael
for Mr. Elrod.
The yard is illuminated by these motion sensored
lights, but each time they go off, Michael
somehow manages to creep closer.
– [Oscar] Hey, where’d you go man?
You’re acting really sketchy right now.
– Logically, it doesn’t make sense that Michael
should be able to move without turning the
lights back on while Oscar can’t, but if
there’s any ability that seems to be focused
on the most in this version of Michael’s
character, it is his ability to disappear.
Part of what makes him so scary and unique
is that despite being a huge immovable force,
he’s incredibly sneaky.
He could be waiting behind any corner or hiding
within any shadow.
Ever since Laurie first spotted him outside
her classroom window, there are many instances
where he’ll be there one moment, but gone
the next.
Perhaps he really does have a power to move
without being seen, and this allows him to
get the best of Oscar and stick a knife in
his back before he’s able to climb over
the Elrod’s fence.
When Oscar’s crush Allyson Nelson comes
back after hearing the commotion, the lights
turn on again, and Michael comes out to greet
her.
(screams)
She runs away and gets help from the police,
so Michael ends up going for a stroll.
He’s spotted and reported on 11th Street,
near Saint Park, where he encounters a police
SUV carrying Hawkins, Sartain and Allyson.
Upon seeing the scourge of Haddonfield, Hawkins
floors it.
Michael continues to walk right towards the
vehicle until the point of impact, demonstrating
the complete lack of fear he saw towards bodily
injury.
Hawkins rams Michael with the vehicle, knocking
him to the sidewalk, where he’s temporarily
knocked out.
To this point, we’ve seen Michael get knocked
out a few times, all of them during the 1978
rampage.
He goes down after getting his neck punctured,
after getting stabbed in the eye and chest,
and finally after getting shot off a balcony.
Each time this happens, he lays there until
he can regain the strength to continue his
spree, something that I refer to as his “recharge
period”.
This scene is the first time we see Michael
recharge in 2018, which represents a terrifying possibility.
Earlier we saw him get shot in the chest and
continue walking like nothing happened.
That fact it takes a hit from a 5,000 lb Chevrolet
to put him down means he may have become even
stronger during his years of captivity.
Or, if we’re going by the theory that Laurie
would later suggest, each of his kills adds
to his power.
– The more he kills, the more transcends
into something else impossible to defeat.
When I covered Michael’s history in the
original timeline, I discussed the possibility
that he has the capability to kind of bear
down and hold off the recharge for a little
bit in critical situations.
It’s possible that this is what happened
here as well.
After getting shot, he held off doing a recharge
until the vehicular impact knocked him out cold.
This is also the longest he’s ever been
sidelined for.
He’s out for 4 minutes and 45 seconds, more
than twice as long as his longest nap to this point.
During this time, Deputy Hawkins is prepared
to shoot him in the head, but Dr. Sartain
gets out to protect the subject of his life’s
research.
When Hawkins refuses to stand down, Sartain
attacks him and drags Michael into the cabin
of the vehicle, where Allyson is currently
locked.
He heads towards Laurie Strode’s house,
hoping to see a reunion between the two.
– [Sartain] Michael’s pursuit of Laurie Strode could
be what keeps him alive.
I would suspect the notion of being the predator
or the fear of becoming prey keeps both of
them alive.
– Laurie had previously expressed a similar
sentiment about her rival.
– He waited for this night.
– He’s waited for me.
I don’t know if her interpretation is accurate,
but if it is, the wait would not have to go
on much longer.
Michael comes to in the back of the cop car
and kicks through the partition hard enough
to basically immobilize him.
Keep in mind, these partitions are made of
steel and they’re literally designed to
keep officers in the front seats safe from
whatever unruly criminals they’re arresting.
The fact that Michael destroys this barrier
in one kick is insane.
He drags his doctor out of the car, allowing
Allyson the chance to escape, but Michael
doesn’t seem to mind, because he’s mostly
concerned with stomping Sartain’s face in.
He crushes the man’s head with one hard
stomp, more evidence that the Shape has kept
himself in shape; he’s not skipping leg
day.
Yeah, take a good look at that one Mikey.
He proceeds to make quick work of the two
cops on standby outside of Laurie’s house,
one gets his throat slashed with the pen blade
acquired from Sartain and the other just straight
up gets turned into a man o’lantern.
No, not that kind of man o’lantern.
This kind looks almost just as painful.
Michael parks the cop car outside of Laurie’s
house and gets the attention of her son-in-law
Ray, so he also gets whacked when Michael
chokes him with a chain.
If we were to give this one a 1978 counterpart,
it would be to Lynda van der Klok, who gets
strangled with a telephone cord and stored
in a closet, which is exactly where Michael
leaves Ray.
But first, he’s got to break into the house.
(breaking glass)
The surprising move nearly kills Laurie.
It makes me think back to an earlier part
of the movie where police told citizens to
stay inside and lock their doors.
When Michael Myers is on the loose, there’s
really no reliable line of defense, because
even Laurie’s fortress is not enough to
withstand Michael’s brute force.
She’s able to raise her shotgun in his direction
and, perhaps in an effort to keep the blast
away from his head, he grabs the end of the
barrel and gets two of his fingers blasted off.
It happens very quickly, and obviously I have
to blur it so that the YouTube Boogeyman doesn’t
come for me in the night, but you can see
right here, as he’s letting go, Michael
is now down to three remaining fingers.
This is a good time to talk about how Michael
handles injuries in this timeline.
Obviously Michael is nearly invincible, there’s
only one way to kill him, and nothing else
seems to affect him much.
But it’s still possible for him to get scars,
and each of his major injuries throughout
the story visibly leaves a mark on him.
The first is when Laurie gets him with the
knitting needle.
The scar can be seen on his neck at the hospital.
Laurie also jabs his eye with a coat hanger.
After the prisoner escape, you can spot a
quick glimpse of the eye, and it’s clouded
over as if to suggest he has lost vision on
that side.
He’s also stabbed and shot in the torso.
We haven’t had the Halloween beach OVA yet,
but if we did ever see him shirtless, I’m
sure those scars would show up as well.
That’s what the Michael Myers fangirls had
in mind when they first heard the title: Halloween H20.
But the point is, it probably would have been
smarter for him to just grab the end of the
gun without covering the cap, because he is
permanently left with three fingers on his
left hand.
This handicap doesn’t really slow him down
too much, but it stands to reason that you
could reduce him into a non-threat if you
eventually removed all of his limbs or something.
This is contrary to the original timeline
and 20 year timeline, where he gets shot in
both eyes and blown up, but he just seems
to regenerate and eventually he looks fine.
The setback doesn’t stop him from breaking
into the house as Laurie retreats to the basement
to shoot up at him through the floorboards.
Instead of going straight for her, he takes
this time to put away Ray’s body, as I mentioned earlier.
He may not be a nice guy, but at least he
keeps things tidy.
Laurie searches the house for him and finds
him in an upstairs bedroom, nearly identical
to the one they fought in 40 years ago.
But for the second time now, she is the aggressor,
and as Dr. Sartain predicted, they are both
vying for that role of the predator.
In ‘78, Michael came after her with a knife,
but she was eventually able to use it against him.
Now Laurie is the one armed with a knife,
but it is Michael who finds a way to use it
against her.
(Laurie grunts)
She also bites his hand,
– Laurie Strode got hungry.
– But this time, Laurie is the one to get thrown
off the balcony, so Michael turns his attention
to her teenage granddaughter.
(door hinges squeak)
(impact)
(somber music)
– Allyson comes home, hoping to find safety
in her grandmother’s protection, but Michael
hears her come in first.
However, this brief distraction gives Laurie
enough time to pull another trick out of Michael’s
book and disappear.
He heads downstairs to try to finish off Laurie’s
bloodline, who are hiding in the basement.
Laurie’s daughter, Karen, begs her mom
to come help her, but it’s a trap.
– Gotcha.
(gunshot)
– In the face!
– Laurie uses this opportunity to emerge from
the shadows and attack!
Michael does land a blow against her with
a fire poker, but the tussle ends with her
grabbing a frying pan to knock him down into
the basement.
This triggers the second recharge period of
the night.
It’s only a few seconds, but that’s just
enough for Allyson and Karen to climb to safety
and shut the bars over the only exit.
Michael finds himself in a basement sized
cage of Laurie’s design.
She’s turning out to be a much more formidable
rival than he remembers her.
She opens the gas valves throughout the house
and all he can do is stare as she tosses a
flare down into the basement, to ignite a
blaze on the man that haunted her nightmares
for her entire adult life.
Still, Michael is unflinching as the room
explodes around him, his empty eyes locked
onto her just as they were since the very
beginning.
One of the benefits of living in a small town
is that it doesn’t take long for the fire department to arrive.
At least, it’s usually a benefit.
One of Haddonfield’s finest falls through
the floorboards into the seemingly empty basement.
Like a spider with a fly in its web, Laurie’s
gun closet opens to reveal Michael Myers.
He brutally uses the firefighter’s own Halligan
bar against him, shattering his protective
mask and face.
His mayday call sends another firefighter
on the way to offer a hand of rescue, but
Michael emerges from the smoke to yank him
into the basement as well.
The efforts of the emergency crew, combined
with the collapsing structure of the house
create a path of escape, and a shape appears
at the doorway.
It’s *The* Shape, charred from the trap
Laurie had left him to die in, but stoic as
ever as he clasps his new weapon with the
8 fingers he has left.
The group of firefighters is well equipped
to fight back with axes, circle saws, and
the power of numbers on their side, but Michael
Myers methodically destroys each of them.
All in all, Michael tears through eleven men.
– Eleven dead bodies.
They’re all first responders.
– Perhaps it is as the young Tommy Doyle suggested
so many years ago.
– You can’t kill the Boogeyman.
– But as I discussed, he’s not immune to injury,
and he’s still nursing that left hand.
He sneaks into the home of Phil and Sondra
Larson, and raids their bathroom for first
aid supplies.
A small drone crash lands in the bathroom,
and probably not knowing what it is, he throws
it out into the living room, getting the attention
of the terrified homeowners.
When Phil comes in and turns the lights on,
he briefly sees Michael, with disinfectant,
a soiled washcloth and bandages spread out
across the sink.
Michael immediately smashes the light, and
Phil locks the door, but Michael powers his
way through a glass window and bludgeons him
against the wall before pulling him down through
the glass shards which puncture his neck.
He does this all almost entirely with his
good hand, only bringing his bandaged hand
up at the end to help grip Phil’s head;
he is quickly learning how to be resourceful
with his remaining fingers.
Sondra takes hold of a small kitchen knife
to defend herself, but Michael has another
idea, and dismounts the fluorescent tube light
from above the stove.
(glass shatters)
(screaming and sobbing)
He sticks it right though her neck and twists.
Before leaving the house, Michael tosses Phil’s
still not dead body onto the table in the
kitchen and sticks knife after knife after
knife into him, until he finally finds one
he likes, and walks outside.
Having taped up his hand and having acquired
a new knife, Michael makes his way home, but
he would have to go across town to get there.
He wanders the streets of Haddonfield as the
clock rolls over into the early hours of November
1st, 2018.
He goes through a park, where he is reportedly
up to his usual stalking antics.
– [Lindsey] Where did you see him?
– He’s just hiding behind trees.
– And he pops out, I’m like, peek-a-boo!
I mean we’re not 3 years old.
Come on man!
– When one of the kids wanders from the group,
Michael gets him without the others noticing.
We don’t see it, but we do see the kid’s
mask, dripping in the aftermath.
These kids appear to be young teenagers, maybe
13, so I’m guessing Michael really does
draw the line, regarding who he’s willing
to kill, between teenagers and pre-teens.
He spots another face from his past talking
to the other 2 teens.
This is Lindsey Wallace, the same girl that
Annie was babysitting before being killed
by Michael 480 months before.
That’s 40 years.
I just wanted to change things up, because
I feel like I keep saying that.
He also discovers an SUV containing Marion
Chambers and two other passengers.
Mimicking what he did to her in 1978, he climbs
on top of the vehicle and grabs her through
the window, but this time she’s armed and
tries to shoot at him through the roof.
When he comes down to meet her face to face,
she’s got a line prepared for him.
– Hey Michael!
This is for Dr. Loomis.
– Ah yes, let’s avenge Dr. Loomis.
The one guy who seemingly died of natural
causes in this timeline.
Fortunately for Michael, her tribute to her
former colleague doesn’t work out, because
she’s out of bullets.
(Marion clicking gun and babbling in fear)
He climbs into the window and stabs her four
times before he’s strangled with a prop
stethoscope by the man in the backseat.
Michael is not affected by this at all, and
sticks the knife into the man’s left eye,
putting an end to the struggle.
Maybe Michael picked that one up from Laurie
Strode.
The man’s wife comes back towards the vehicle
with a handgun, and Michael’s quick thinking
results in a kill that would probably be more
at home in an FPS montage than a Halloween movie.
(airhorns and cheering)
As Michael does his trademark corpse admiration
head tilt, he gets a surprise bag of bricks
to the face from Lindsey.
Despite being one of the four survivors of
the babysitter murders, she vastly underestimates
him, and he chokeslams her against the car.
However, her experience does help her, because
she’s able to use the same tactic that Laurie
once used to get away from his grip, by removing
The Boogeyman’s mask.
After readjusting it, he follows her into
the woods at his customary walking pace.
We are now moving at the speed of… pretty
slow but somehow intimidating.
Shortly thereafter, the couple from the SUV
is somehow moved to the carousel at the park,
and Marion is decorated with the Witch mask
left behind by the teens and hung from the
top of the swingset.
We literally see Michael leave the scene to
look for Lindsey, so the only explanation
is that he went back to rearrange the bodies.
Which, to be fair, is consistent with his
character.
Annie, Lynda and Bob were arranged in a scene
in ‘78, and he also pays special attention
to the presentation of Vicky and Ray earlier
on this night in 2018.
Seeing this trend repeated so many times makes
me automatically start searching for a reason
behind it.
As with many aspects of the character, we’ll
probably never get a definitive answer, so
all I can do is use the clues and speculate.
The first scene was clearly a recreation of
his sister’s grave site, which is something
that happened when Michael was a kid, and
this one depicts the bodies playing at a playground,
somewhere you would usually find kids.
Michael was a child during his first killing,
and we know he has psychological issues -- he’s
been in a mental hospital for 55 years.
Maybe his childhood trauma prevented him from
maturing out of a childlike mindset.
Maybe he sees these bodies as toys that he
can play with and maybe he avoids killing
kids because he sees them as one of his own
kind.
His next destination would also play into
this idea.
Because Michael Myers would return to his
childhood home.
(impact)
(mellow music)
The first time Michael broke out of Smith’s
Grove, he visited his former residence and
found it abandoned.
It was in a dilapidated state, but other than
the natural effects of time, it was unaltered.
This time, the property no longer sat empty.
He would find it occupied by two men: Big
John and Little John.
He sneaks in through the back door, probably
because this was the entrance he used shortly
before killing Judith.
I also find it interesting that he leaves
behind a three fingered handprint on the doorframe.
It almost looks like a dinosaur track, which
seems appropriate given Tommy’s speech at
the hospital.
– He is an apex predator!
– The way Dr. Sartain describes him compares
him to another apex predator, a shark.
– He only knows how to keep moving and keep
killing.
And he will kill again unless he’s captured.
– This is actually no mistake.
In an interview with HalloweenMovies.com,
director David Gordon-Green explains how he
used Jaws, almost like a template for this
iteration of Michael Myers.
“In some ways, it's like a film like Jaws.
There's not a lot of personality in the shark.
Technically he's very elusive and we're trying
to keep that as our framework and not get
too much into who he is, why he is, or what
he's been doing.”
It sounds like this approach was also communicated
to mask designer Christopher Nelson.
– [Nelson] And it ended up being this very
strange mannequin-like soulless, almost Great
white shark of a human.
– In this scenario, much like the opening scene
of Jaws, the predator stalks its prey silently.
Michael sneaks around upstairs and gets the
draw on Big John without ever being noticed.
And squeezes his eyes out of their sockets
just for good measure.
After this, Michael resumes the position he
took as a child, just staring out his sister’s
bedroom window.
When Little John addresses him, he turns and
approaches.
It is not long before he joins his partner
in death.
– [Little John] Noooo!!!
– He poses the remains of the two Johns just
like a photo found in their study, only their
positions are switched.
I don’t have time to explain the significance
of that here, but watch my Things You Missed
in Halloween Kills after this if you’re
interested.
Another trait of Michael’s that we’ve
seen come up time and time again is his love
of darkness.
There’s one I can relate to.
We saw him turn off all the lights after taking
over the Wallace house in 1978, and he follows
suit here after reclaiming his own residence.
This makes it easier for him to hide in the
shadows and hunt his prey.
The next victim is Lonnie Elam, the kid that
Michael briefly encountered just outside the
Myers house after escaping from Dr. Loomis.
Now that he’s no longer a kid, he’s a
perfectly viable target.
He makes quick work of Lonnie and throws him
into the attic, then hides in a closet and
waits for someone to come looking for him.
And that someone is Lonnie’s teenage son
Cameron.
Michael bursts out of the closet and pins
him to the wall where he is able to stab him
several times.
Cameron’s girlfriend, Allyson, comes marching
with a shotgun, which he easily deflects,
but she’s able to land several knife jabs
into his stomach before he slams her face
into a railing and tosses her down the stairs.
As he finishes Cameron, Allyson challenges
him to come get her, in hopes of creating
a distraction, but he doesn't come for her until after breaking Cameron’s
neck with a 180° twist.
Allyson is nowhere near a match for Michael’s
quick reflexes and strength, but she’s saved
when her mom shows up to save the day by stabbing
Michael in the back with the pitchfork
found on the front porch.
This is actually one of the most effective
attacks that we’ve ever seen against him,
he actually appears to recoil in pain for
a moment as he’s driven to the ground.
What makes this pitchfork so effective as
opposed to the stabs and gunshots he’s endured
all night long?
In my opinion, this goes back to the recharge
period.
Imagine Michael is like a Pokémon,
just hang with me for a second here!
He has a set amount of Health Points.
Each attack against him will lower his HP,
but they won’t slow him down until his bar
reaches zero.
Once that happens, he faints and has to rest
for a little while before his health is restored,
at which point he can go on fighting again.
You can make him faint all you want, but that
doesn’t mean he’s going to die.
He’s not Gary’s Raticate.
(Lavender Town syndrome music)
So the pitchfork, and the subsequent head
stomp was probably just the final blow, the
last of Michael’s HP.
This recharge period is pretty short though,
just long enough for Karen to steal Michael’s
mask, which tracks now as a well tested method
to distract him from anything else.
He totally ignores the vulnerable Allyson
and walks after Karen, who goads him on, through
backyards and side yards, into another
street, which turns out to be yet another trap.
He’s surrounded by an angry mob of Haddonfield
townspeople and their obnoxiously big trucks.
F*ck cars.
They’re led by Leigh Brackett, the father
of the babysitter Annie, whose life he famously
cut short 40 years before, and by Tommy Doyle,
the boy that Laurie was babysitting during
her encounter with Michael that same night.
The mob is armed with firearms, hockey sticks,
shovels, pipes, baseball bats, and one lady
even brings an iron.
Not a golf club, but like a clothing iron,
for some reason.
With Michael surrounded, they’re able to
overwhelm him by attacking from his blind
side, burying close range shots into him and
turning up the beatdown once he hits the pavement.
He drops his knife, and barely has the strength
to reach for it, so Karen, the woman whose
life was spent preparing for Michael’s onslaught,
grabs it and slashes it into his upper back.
It looks like it may be over for Michael,
that he had finally met his match.
Just to be sure, Brackett lines up his gun
to Myers head, but in one quick motion, the
evil being draws the knife from his own back
and uses it to slash through Brackett’s throat.
From here, Michael’s abilities seem to grow.
Laurie Strode has the theory about Michael’s
tendency to seemingly become more and more
difficult to defeat.
She believes that the more he kills, the more
transcends into something else impossible
to take down.
I guess my Pokémon analogy is actually perfect
to describe this too.
In Pokémon, the more monsters you defeat,
the more experience you gain, which eventually
levels you up.
After taking out Leigh Brackett, Michael seems
to get a boost in his abilities, and the same
attackers he was overwhelmed by moments earlier
are now outmaneuvered, overpowered, and with
a little bit of luck… come on people of
Haddonfield, you gotta learn to keep track
of how much ammunition you have left… he
takes each of them down until it’s just
him and Tommy.
When Michael deals the finishing blow, the
two lock eyes…
sort of.
Michael looks into Tommy’s eyes but Tommy
can only see the dark voids of shadow created
by the mask.
When covered by the mask under the fall of
night, the facial features that make him human
just aren’t visible, another example of
incongruent affect.
With the entire mob taken care of, Michael
returns to his post, sneaking past the commotion
of emergency vehicles and crime scene investigators
to return to Judith’s old bedroom.
He finds Karen, standing at his spot, gazing
out the window, but by the time she notices
him in the reflection, it’s already too
late for her.
Karen is killed, and The Shape retakes his
rightful place atop Haddonfield.
– [Dr Sartain] How does a crime like Michael's
affect him?
What's that feeling?
Is he on a random path or is he emotionally
driven?
Triggered by something.
Perhaps some unheard marching order imprinted on his
very being?
I want to know what he’s feeling.
I want to know what pleasure he gets out of killing.
– Dr. Sartain, in his quest to understand the
mind of a killer, nearly became a killer himself.
He wanted to gain more insight into Michael
by observing him in the wild.
As misguided as this may have been, could
it be argued that seeing Michael break free
for a third time helps us understand him?
Helps us identify his patterns?
Helps us understand the mind of a killer?
Maybe.
It’s up to your interpretation if any of
the analysis provided in this video, or any
of your own conclusions hold any more ground
than any of the 50 psychiatrists who examined
him in captivity.
Personally, to this point, I feel pretty good
about all of my teachings here in this lesson,
but I’d still hesitate to call them definitive.
Mostly because of what happens next.
Just when we think we’re starting to understand
Michael…
the pattern breaks.
He doesn’t go back into captivity as you
would expect.
This time, Michael gets away.
(impact)
(mysterious music)
“A manhunt for suspected killer Michael
Myers continues in Haddonfield, Illinois on
Friday, two days after 27 people were brutally
killed on Halloween night.
The suspect, Michael Myers, 61, is believed
to have fled the area and is currently at large.
He is in possession of a knife and considered
armed and very dangerous.”
That’s what newspapers read in early November
after Michael Myers's worst crime spree yet.
However, they were wrong about two things.
The first being Michael’s kill count.
They probably haven’t even tallied all the
bodies, yet, because it’s more like 57,
give or take a few whose fate is never explicitly
seen.
The second error is that Michael did not necessarily
leave the area.
At this time, he most likely retreated to
the sewers where he could easily lay low while
the drama died down.
I imagine at some point he tried to go back
home, but found his old residence demolished,
and ended up just staying in the sewer.
Over the next 4 years, there were other Halloween
murders, which were ultimately determined
to be inspired by Michael, but not committed
by Michael himself.
There were also people who went missing around
Halloween and never turned up, like Meagan
Baxter, in October 2021.
Despite the fact that police did not name
Michael Myers as the culprit for any of this,
it is likely that he did take in a few victims
during this time, based on the comments of
this homeless man who hangs out around the
sewer entrance.
– You see that man in there?
He’ll take people in there now and then.
Why’d he let you live?
– We have no way of knowing which victims were taken by
Michael, and which were taken by other
people, because the police seem like they
are just taking educated guesses rather than
getting real evidence, for some reason.
– Do you think he's come back?
– Michael doesn’t use guns.
I really don’t understand that logic.
Just because Michael has not fired a gun in
the past doesn’t mean he isn’t going to.
He never killed anyone with a Halligan bar…
until he did.
Plus, one of his victims did die from a gunshot,
even if he wasn’t the one to fire it.
I’m guessing he mostly just killed people
near the sewer entrance though, in order to
keep a lower profile.
For example, Meagan Baxter’s missing billboard
is right near this overpass, and it makes
sense that they would want to place this near
the location she was believed to have disappeared,
so she was probably taken by Michael.
In October 2022, a young man named Corey Cunningham
is tossed from the overpass into the hobo camp,
where he is abducted by Michael, who drags
him into the sewers.
Strangely he doesn’t kill Corey while he’s
passed out.
As he tries to escape, Michael reaches out
and tries to strangle him, during which they
make eye contact, and something seems to be
passed between the two, and Corey escapes.
We’re not really given a reason that Michael
lets Corey live, but we are given a reason
for Allyson’s attraction to Corey.
– I know what it’s like to have everybody
looking at you thinking that they know you,
thinking that they know what you’ve been
through, but they don’t.
– So maybe Michael relates to Corey on a similar
level.
Then on October 29th, Corey leads a police
officer named Doug Mulaney into the sewer
where Michael is waiting for him.
Michael jumps Officer Mulaney, but Mulaney
is able to get the upper hand and knock Michael
to the floor.
But Corey intervenes by attacking Mulaney,
and begs Michael to show him how he kills.
Michael grabs a rusted old knife, probably
the same one from the Larsens’ house, and
Corey restrains Mulaney, giving Michael the
opportunity to slash his throat and stab him
over and over.
We can see the life and power return to Michael’s
body as he does this, and he stabs Mulaney
several times more each with increasing tempo
and power.
It appears that Laurie’s theory is partially
correct, the more that Michael kills, the
more powerful he becomes.
However, at this point, he seems weaker than
he was in 2018.
My first thought was that long periods without
killing can drain his power, however, that
doesn’t exactly track with his escape four
years prior.
He had not killed anyone during his 40 year
stay at Smith’s Grove, yet, he still had
the power to overtake the entire bus full
of armed guards.
So it could be that Michael’s power is fading
as he gets older, and he needs to continue
to kill in order to maintain his strength.
Another thought I’m stewing with is that
maybe killing is not what gives him power,
but maybe his status as the boogeyman is what
gives him power.
This would explain why his power builds through
1978, but Laurie, the one character who doesn’t
believe in the Boogeyman, survives.
Then in 2018, his notoriety had grown even
greater.
We literally see reporters coming to Haddonfield
from across the globe to investigate him.
With each victim he took that year, he became
even more infamous, which makes it appear
as if each kill is actually powering him up.
But then in 2019, Corey Cunningham killed
the kid he was babysitting and he became the
new villain of Haddonfield.
Michael was now sharing the boogeyman spotlight,
and some of that power went to Corey, not to Michael.
– I keep seeing his eyes.
Michael’s eyes.
In Corey.
– The one snag in this theory is that he kills
Officer Mulaney in private.
Before the town learns about his death, we
see the power immediately go back to Michael.
However, there is one witness to this: Corey.
Even if he is just an audience of one, Michael
is still bringing life back into the urban
legend, which in turns literally gives life
to the legend himself.
It’s something I’ve brought up several
times throughout his history, so Michael’s
status as an urban legend may be important
here as well.
After this, Michael follows Corey, who goes
back to Laurie’s new house, where he witnesses
the woman he’s become all too familiar with
over the last 44 years spying in her own windows,
at a young couple, much like he did as a child.
The next night he follows Corey again, this
time to the home of Dr. Mathis, Allyson’s ***hole boss.
He watches as the young man in the scarecrow
mask takes him out.
Corey is unable to reach Mathis’s girlfriend
before she locks him out of the house, but
Michael is already there waiting for her.
He puts his full power on display for the
first time in four years by pinning her up
against the wall with his knife, as he had
with Bob Simms and Dave in the past.
Earlier I talked about Michael’s head tilt
being a sign that he is admiring his kill
like artwork, and that idea is furthered here,
because Deborah is pinned up over a large painting.
The next day is an important one: October
31st.
Halloween fell upon Haddonfield once again,
and it would not pass without their infamous
boogeyman paying them one final visit.
(impact)
(horror soundscape)
(dripping)
Michael’s favorite holiday begins on a low
note, with Corey charging into the sewers,
picking a fight with him, pinning him to the
ground and stealing his mask.
As he does this, he says “you’re just
a man in a Halloween mask”.
Perhaps he is able to overpower Michael because
of this belief that he’s nothing more than
an ordinary man.
He could not have been more wrong.
As we’ve seen time and time again, Michael
will stop at nothing to get his mask back.
He somehow tracks Corey to Laurie Strode’s
house and sneaks in through the back door
to reclaim his mask once again.
By the time Michael gets there, Corey appears
to be laying dead in the foyer, but when the
Shape reaches down to take his knife, he springs
to life and grabs Michael’s hand.
It would appear that Corey has just had his
own “recharge period”, but I’ll come
back to that a little bit later.
This time, Michael is the apex predator once
more, and he snaps Corey’s neck.
Now he can turn his attention back to Laurie
Strode for one last showdown.
He goes into the kitchen, drawn to the hum
of the microwave, before hearing movement
from a closet.
Before opening it, the contents of the microwave
pops, but meal that Michael is served is not
the one he was hoping for.
Because Laurie uses the distraction to bust
out of the closet and knock the knife loose
from his hands using a fire extinguisher.
How ironic that 11 fully equipped firemen
couldn’t manage to disarm Michael, but little
old Laurie Strode with a fire extinguisher
could.
However, he’s still able to grab hold of
her and smash her face against a china cabinet.
He throws her down and stomps his boot onto
her throat, so she won’t be able to get
out of this one by simply removing his mask,
because she can’t reach.
Instead, she retaliates by kicking his other
knee.
The tussle continues on, with one notable
moment being when Michael turns on the garbage
disposal and tries to force her hand into
it.
Not only is this an homage to a scene from
Halloween H20, but from Michael’s point
of view, it’s revenge for their battle four
years earlier, where Laurie blasted off his
fingers with the shotgun.
This was probably the most damage that anyone
had ever done to him, because as I mentioned,
Michael can’t just grow back fingers in
this timeline, so he’s looking to get even
with her by mangling a few of hers.
However, she’s able to get out of this with
a well-placed headbutt, and there just happens
to be a knitting needle lying around, so she
tries that attack again, seeing as how it
worked in 1978, but this time, he is prepared.
Once again, he tries to get his revenge on
her, by impaling her face with the needle
in the same spot that she once got him, and
this time he is successful.
But, it comes at a cost, because this time,
she does manage to get close enough to remove
his mask and the momentary distraction allows
her to pin his hand to the counter with his
own knife, leaving him only one arm to work
with.
She somehow manages to pin him down to the
kitchen island, reach into her own knife drawer
and drive the blade into his heart.
Ironically, this leaves him in a very similar
position to the one he left Phil Larson in
four Halloweens prior.
I discussed the possibility that Michael can
hold off the recharge period sometimes, and
continue to power through to get himself out
of a critical situation, and I’m guessing
that’s what happens here, because it only
takes four seconds for him to sit up, with
so much force that he throws Laurie off of
him.
With it abundantly clear that she won’t
be able to kill Michael, or even slow him
down with recharge periods, her only option
is to try to immobilize him, which she does
by pinning his other hand down to the counter
with the knife, and using the frying pan like
a hammer to push the metaphorical nail in
metaphorical crucifix.
He squirms when he realizes he’s now totally
defenseless, but just to be safe, Laurie also
topples her refrigerator, pinning his leg
to the island.
Michael is truly immobilized for the first
time.
Even the trap she left him to die in at her
old home still gave him the freedom to move
around the basement and eventually escape.
Now, he truly could not go anywhere, and Laurie
takes advantage of the situation by grabbing
her chef’s knife, the tool that Michael
favored and used to destroy so many families,
and forced him to look at his own reflection
one last time.
After all, if Deputy Hawkins’s interpretation
is to be believed Michael was never looking
out the window at the Myers House, he was
looking in at his reflection.
Laurie jabs her rival in the side, then, for
one last time, removes his mask, and looks
into his real face.
There is a supposed phenomena among initial
viewers of the original 1978 Halloween film.
Many audience members reported seeing a deformed
face during the scene where Laurie first removed
his mask, but in reality, it was just the
actual face of actor Tony Moran, with some
spooky lighting and a small injury prosthetic,
meant to represent the damage that Laurie
had done with the coathanger in the prior
scene.
I can only imagine the blow to Tony’s confidence
was more damaging than anything any boogeyman
can do, but the consensus is that because
of the atmosphere, the audience was projecting
their expectations of horror and their own
fears when they watched that scene.
The 2022 unmasking has the opposite effect,
because Michael really is kind of deformed
at this point, through multiple stabs and
gunshots to the face, and of course, the blaze
that seems to have melted his ear off and
left him with burns that nearly rival one
Mr. Frederick Krueger.
However this time we don’t get a direct
look at his face, leaving part of the horror
up the imagination of the viewer.
Laurie slashes cleanly through Michael’s
throat with a sense of finality… but Michael
Myers is truly even closer to invincibility
than even she believes.
He has to rip his hand out of the knife, effectively
splitting it in two, but it doesn’t matter,
because he’s still able to grip his fingers
around Laurie’s throat, a vice that she
cannot escape from.
Strangely, she seems to egg him on from this
position.
– Do it.
Do it!
– Four years ago, her granddaughter had a similar
line when Michael had her cornered at the
Myers house with death as the only visible
outcome.
But it turned out she was talking to her mother,
who was standing behind him with the pitchfork.
Laurie’s words here are also directed at
someone else; this time it’s Allyson who
gets to play the savior.
She pulls Michael’s arm away from her Grandmother
and ****ing breaks it on the side of the counter!
Wow I did not think she had that in her.
With her airways free, Laurie slits Michael’s
wrist, which she seems to naively think this
is the end of him when Deputy Hawkins arrives
on the scene with police.
– Michael.
– He’s dead.
– Not dead enough.
I’m glad someone has some common sense here.
It seems like Allyson’s the only one who
is aware of the recharge period.
Michael is moved to the roof of vehicle and
tied down with rope.
I would honestly go with something a little
bit sturdier, knowing Michael, but that’s just me.
Police lead a procession towards the junkyard,
and many other Haddonfield residents join
in to ensure that there’s no wiggle room
for Michael to pull some kind of miraculous
escape, as he had in 2018.
He is untied and involuntarily crowd surfed
to the industrial shredder.
Carefully, he’s a villain.
In the end, it is Laurie, the woman who lost
her best friends, her daughter, her son-in-law,
and so many who were close to her, who rolls
Michael’s body into the gears, where it
is completely crushed and shredded into bits.
There would be no tombstone.
No memorial.
Only the legend of the boogeyman.
But even with his body completely destroyed,
is this the end of the boogeyman?
Maybe.
But maybe not.
(impact)
(haunting piano music)
Is this truly the end of Michael Myers?
Has the Halloween franchise finally run its
course?
Sure, they could always start a new timeline
branch or do another reboot, but for the purposes
of this video, let’s focus on the 40-Year
iteration of Michael Myers.
It is certainly the end of Michael Myers,
the man.
We’ve seen throughout this timeline that
his injuries are permanent, and he gets his
entire body ripped to shreds, so there’s
no coming back from that.
But in Halloween Ends, we saw Michael’s
evil infect other people in the town of Haddonfield.
It started with random crimes on Halloween
night, but it really took hold on Corey Cunningham,
who started to go down the same path as Michael,
eventually developing an inexplicable desire
for the mask, and even coming back from a
mortal wound after a short recharge period.
We don’t see what happens to him, he’s
left laying in Laurie’s foyer and we never
find out if he comes back to life again.
If you’re not familiar, Halloween franchise
producer Moustapha Akkad created a special
clause in the contract for each Halloween
film.
The filmmakers were legally not allowed to
kill Michael Myers, so that Akkad could continue
making money off the IP forever, which he
did.
Which is why Michael’s apparent death in
H20 was retconned in Resurrection, the filmmakers
made a deal with him where they were allowed
to make it look like Michael had died, but
they had to undo it at the start of the next
film, so they came up with this whole scenario,
where Michael switched costumes with the EMT,
and that’s whose head got cut off.
It’s really dumb, but it’s also another
reason that Michael being unmasked during
his death in Halloween Ends is significant,
because Laurie can see that she’s actually
killing the right guy.
Moustapha Akkad died in 2005, but I’ve heard
that his son Malek Akkad includes the same
clause in his contracts.
I can’t help but wonder if the ambiguity
behind Corey Cunningham’s fate was another
deal with the Akkad family.
Malek allows Michael Myers to meet his end
at 64 years old, and in exchange, Corey becomes
the new Michael.
Corey is 21, just like Michael was during
the original movie.
So they could potentially start again from
there.
I’m not saying that’s what I think is
going to happen.
It probably makes more sense to just start
another timeline branch or go back to the
anthology franchise idea and do some other
stories that take place on Halloween night,
like what they did with Halloween III.
That’s personally what I want to see.
But aside from the potential contractual reason
that it ended as it did, I think there’s
an artistic reason as well.
Perhaps this was the end that David Gordon
Green and Danny McBride wanted, because of
the message it sends.
Perhaps they wanted us to feel like the evil
that drove Michael Myers is alive and well
in Corey Cunningham, or even in somebody else.
The opening credits of Halloween Ends show
a constant cycle of jack o’lantern rebirths
and there’s also this scene where Lindsey
does tarot cards with Allyson.
– [Lindsey] That just means a major phase is ending
and a new one is about to begin.
– The most overused phrase in this trilogy was
“evil dies tonight”, to the point that
it kind of became a meme, but if there’s
anything that I took away from the end of
this Michael’s story, it’s that you can
stop one evil person, but you can never totally
defeat evil.
There will always be evil in the world.
There’s no point in turning your house into
a fortress and obsessively trying to stop
it, because there will always be another evil
on the horizon.
If you enjoyed this video, I’ve also analyzed
the original timeline of Michael Myers, so
if you’re interested in how that character
differs from this one, check out that video
on the left.
And if you love scary movies, that is exactly
what I cover on this channel, so go ahead
and subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring the deathbell and select
all notifications so you don’t miss any
uploads and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.